you start lights go out Jocasta
[Music]
please don't you're my contact what are
my instructions
your instructions are to go back to your
pod anyway I'm going to save the world
yes you're gonna save the world but not
if you blow our cover
[Music]
mr. Milgram were you diagnosed with
schizophrenia ten years ago a new life
that's all I want
not what's normal anyway why are you
here I am depressed and I have been for
a very long time
I believe in this treatment and I
believe that we can all be fixed and
help sound Steven
that doesn't sound stupid to me did I
find you who are you supposed to find me
there's farm I separate them they just
find their way brought together maybe
these two have a cosmic connection
or just two people
looking out for each other
[Music]
do you know where you are right now I'm
in a drug trial what do you think is
wrong with you I'm sick I don't matter
what would you say this trial is showing
you about yourself this therapy now it's
not therapy
it's science once you begin to
appreciate the structure of the mind
there's no reason to believe that
anything about us can't be changed pain
can be destroyed the mind can be solved
how many of your subjects have ended up
catatonic zero my head doesn't work
right I thought maybe these people can
fix me sounds stupid
that doesn't sound stupid to me okay
people let's begin
my mind is playing tricks
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a multi reality brain magic [ __ ]
I don't know what's real what's not
[Music]
something's wrong what did you do
every time I separate them they just
find their way back together
not protecting those people in there
you
[Music]
you